in the last few videos we constructed a
marginal product revenue curve for our
little competitive car wash and we
essentially figured out how this is
really just the demand curve for labor
from this firm and I talked about in the
very first video that if you know the
demand curve for in a certain market and
this is the market for labor of a
certain kind maybe the type of labor
that would work at a car wash then if
you knew it from one firm and all the
other firms in the market for that type
of labor you could add their demand
curves to get the entire market demand
for that type of labor for that good or
service and what I want to do in this
video is make sure you understand what
it means to add demand curves it's on
one level straightforward but on some
one another level little not intuitive
because of the ways that the axes are
defined in economics that the price axis
is the vertical axis so let's draw the
demand curve for two firms and I'll do
simplified versions I won't use this one
right over here I'll just do two
simplified demand curves and this
doesn't apply just to labor markets this
applies to any demand curve so if I want
to add to demand curves so this is one
one entities demand so let's say this is
one firms demand
so that's price and this is quantity
this is quantity and let's say at a
price of 10 they demand nothing if
that's the hourly wages and if the price
were zero they would they would
essentially get up to they would demand
ten people and so you have a situation
you have a demand curve that would look
something a band curve that would look
something like that dot the demand curve
that would look like that I'll do one
other point on the demand curve at a
price of five a quantity or $5 per hour
this firm would demand if we're thinking
of it in terms of labor at a price of $5
per hour of labor this firm would demand
five people per hour and obviously what
I'm going to do is general to any demand
car but we'll just keep it in the labor
mindset so this is firm one this is a
firm's demand firm one if we're talking
about this demand for oranges and this
wouldn't be a firm this would be a
consumer or
or maybe a wholesaler or something like
that so this is firm ones demand for
labor and let's say firm 2's demand
looks something like this and I'll try
to align them so firm 2's demand looks
something like this and the axes are
going to have the exact same labels this
is quantity this is price right over
here this is 5 this is 10 and then this
is 15 and let's say that this is this is
5 and let's say this is 6 right over
here and their demand curve looks like
this
it looks so like that let me make it a
little bit neater it looks that was less
neat it looks something like that and I
could put some extra points here at a
price of 10 this firm will demand 2
units if we're the labor $10 per hour
they'll get 2 people per hour at a price
of 5 they will demand for they will
demand 4 units so these are all we've
looked at a couple of points on this
demand curve and now we are ready to add
them together so this is firm to firm
2's demand for labor so let's add these
two curves and what I said is
unintuitive is that we're actually going
to look at for a given price how much
total quantity of labor is now demanded
so we're going to essentially add it
horizontally you're going to see what
I'm talking about in a second so when I
add them together I add them together
I'm going to have the same axes so this
is let's say this is 5 this is 10
actually let me get a little bit further
on this axis on this second axis so the
second axis let me get as straight as
possible so let's say that this is 5 10
15 5 10 15 and this is 5 10 15 I'm doing
my best to align it horizontally that
this 15 is this 15 that this 10 is with
this 10 with is with that 10 and that 5
is with that 5 and with that 5 so at a
price of 15 in the market what is the
total quantity demanded well it's still
going to be 0 because even this firm is
still demanding 0 but then if we go if
we go to a price of
and this firm the firm one is demanding
zero but firm two over here is demanding
two so we're going to go ten it's going
to be right over there
this is right about to that distance is
right about two and then if we go to
five at a price of five firm one is
going to demand five firm two is going
to demand four units of labour so at a
price of five you're going to have five
plus four so the price of five you're
going to have five plus four or nine
units of labour nine units of labour and
then at a price of zero if Labour is
free this firm would demand ten units
this firm would demand six units you add
them together you get sixteen units so
you'd get sixteen units so the combined
the combined the demand for labor curve
will look something like I'll do it or
actually do it in blue
the combined demand for labor curve will
look like this between 15 and $10 only
firm one is interested in getting any
labor so this part right over here will
look just like that but then after that
point you can essentially add firm one
to the mix and then firm one now maybe
I'll do that part in a different color
it'll look something like it'll look
something like like that we've
essentially added we've horizontally
added this line to this line you could
imagine taking this line and at any
given point so at five right over here
you're taking its value in quantity and
adding to this quantity here and the
reason why I said this is a little bit
non-intuitive is this would have been
easier at least for me to add with kind
of the background or the traditional
algebraic conventions we're used to
we're used to adding kind of vertically
so if we were to flip price and quantity
then we could kind of stack these on top
of each other and add them vertically
and that's why it's a little
non-intuitive but hopefully this makes
sense we're just looking at each of
their demand curves at any given price
we're seeing okay what is the demand
from firm two what is the demand from
firm one and we're adding them together
and then we get this we get this
combined market demand curve firm 1 plus
firm 2